hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of thrones if you'd like to
watch the full video head over to
youtube.com slash games but time now for
a segment I mean in my notes I've just
written goddamnit bran because I mean we
said this a couple weeks ago right that
everything in Westeros is pretty much
Brian's fault and now confirmed
everything is Browns fault so I mean in
this episode alone he caused the death
of summer leaf yep all of the children
in the forest of tired children in the
forest so they're pretty much extinct
now I mean though it was set up they
were like oh yeah they created the White
Walkers so they did the bad thing and
now they're all dead but it was
Brownsville the three-eyed Raven
that was brand's fault time was gonna do
that for us though that's true and hold
off so thanks Brian but what's also kind
of definitely been confirmed now is that
not only can bran seemingly travel
through time with his his dreams he can
influence people he can be heard and he
can also be touched so where else in the
series could he have been I think we
were saying so Mad King Aerys when but
just before he threatened to burn King's
Landing he said the same thing he'd been
saying for hours do you think that was a
brand joint oh like 90% a brand joint I
think we've seen in the trailer
something that might be a flashback and
to Jamie doing his King Slayer thing I
think there's definitely gonna be a
flashback around then and brands already
there he might as well mess everything
up mm-hmm there's an interesting theory
about because I mean a lot of the Starks
are called Brandon mm-hmm it was Brandon
builder there was his uncle who was also
called Brian and it's sort of
interesting that there was a story read
to them by old nan where she keeps
confusing the brands and so now people
are like wait what if all the brands are
the same which is kind of blowing my
mind what do we think is that I think
that might be a bit far I think he could
be
one of the brands they believe the
younger brother and the Builder I think
he could easily be but maybe not all the
brands and there's a lot of you know
everyone has the same name in Game of
Thrones yeah so it might be a
coincidence I'm fine with that well at
one point Ned does say to area after
area says like he can't be a knight
anymore no someday he could be Lord of a
holdfast or sit on the King's Council
what am I raise castles I'm Brandon the
Builder so that could just be some
insane foreshadowing or maybe just a
throwaway comment I mean to be honest
with the whole Hodor yeah they should
like foreshadow age so anything is
possible
and speaking of Brian the Builder I
think it's time to talk about the wall
because I'm getting this really weird
feeling that it's gonna come tumbling
down soon it was built it's it's you
know buttload of ice but also magic and
it means that the White Walkers can't
come past it pretty much like where the
three-eyed Raven was they couldn't come
past the magic but now the brands been
touched that magic see me doesn't work
in areas that he's in so basically if he
goes past the wall now does that mean
that the White Walkers can follow him is
that why the night's king kind of let
him go at the end I think that could be
the big cliffhanger of this series yes
something to do with the wall some
Easter with the White Walkers coming
past a certain point yeah and it's a
Song of Ice and Fire
they're definitely the ice you're gonna
happen also the last thing that John
says to Dolores ed when he leaves the
wall is don't look it down while I'm
gone I'm doing the best so John's fault
so it's fall birds might be like Eden
like the thirty dudes there left might
be yeah end on a nice round number
thousandth Lord Commander might as well
yeah but also sintra see where brands
gonna go from here because in the books
they were supposed to meet cold hands
who is kind of this half I guess we were
you know he's kind of like a like a
white like a white
but he's sort of regain he's kept his
human side strongly speculated that he
is Benjamin Benjen stark Ned's brother
who was a member of the Nights Watch I
don't know could that be who mirror
meets up with because she can't carry
him myself I mean people really like the
Benjen equals Daario equals your own
theory benjin is all of us engine equals
all the men with slightly long hair why
don't but now I think sis I mean I think
this is pretty much we're finally
getting more of a like a road map of
where the series is heading now so if
the wall does come down the ice
definitely comes down with it they'll
come further and further south
if Daenerys does come across from a
sauce so even if it's on her own ships
or if it's on your ships or if it's on
your own ships also your on is like I
won a thousand ships like in ten minutes
build me a thousand ships and I will
give you this world
don't know how he thinks I'm building
works these guardians and build sheets
turned on pretty much so that's the fire
element I'm just really interested to
see like that's the Song of Ice and Fire
where does John fit on into all of it
where are the Starks gonna fit into the
rest of it yeah man
just want to see some dragons melt some
ice dudes and some zombies on fire an
interesting thing I noticed in this
episode is that we now have mirror and
bran going down to the wall possibly
even to Winterfell because of course
Bryan wants to go back to Winterfell
hmm so we've got a reed in a stock what
else have we seen that I swear to God if
we don't discover what's in the Tower of
joy yeah I'm gonna riot
you